hello I'm mock Spellman I'm the global
head of strategy at accenture and one of
the things I've been doing today is
looking at the whole question about
winning strategies in competitiveness
and what was very interesting was i
started the session by asking people
whether were optimistic or pessimistic
about the future prospects the
competitiveness in europe as opposed to
central asia and what transpired was
that people were more pessimistic about
the prospects in europe whereas they
were more optimistic about the prospects
in central asia and when we went on to
explore that i think there were a number
of interesting sort of issues
particularly related to skills relates
to innovation and also to the access to
finance clearly a lot of central asia
has strong natural resources i think the
feeling is that with good positive
foreign direct investment those
opportunities to grow and clearly a lot
of competitiveness relates to underlying
growth rates prospects for that growth
and labour productivity I think the
sense in Europe though is that we've got
a big challenge particularly with aging
and demographics how we raise and boost
productivity skills but critically how
do we raise much more of an
entrepreneurial culture and how do we
make the dynamism and VIN evasion which
we see in pockets around different parts
of Europe really scale that and make
that happen and so it was a very
interesting debate and I think clearly
when you look at innovation and when you
look at talent and and finance you have
to get the balance right between
short-term measures and long-term
measures thank you